hi i'm lauren from khan academy and
today i'm going to give you an overview
of how to set up accounts for yourself
and your children on khan academy we'll
also go over how you can find relevant
content for your kids and view their
progress
this video is meant for parents with
kids who are 13 or older if your child
is 12 or younger please see our other
video called parent quick start tips for
kids ages 12 and under
we recommend that you and your child go
through the account creation steps
together and collaborate to come up with
a plan for learning on khan academy to
begin go to
www.khanacademy.org and have your child
click sign up in the upper right corner
on the sign up page have your child
enter their date of birth
and sign up via google or facebook
or create a username and password and
sign up with
email next your child can select their
grade level and click continue
on the next page you'll see courses that
we recommend for your child based on
their grade level have them choose one
or more and click continue
you can also use the see all link to
view the full menu in case your child
would like to select other topics that
interest them
now your child is ready to go they can
click the blue start button for any
course to start with the very first
lesson or click the see all link to
browse the entire course
if your child is not sure where to start
here's a tip
most khan academy math courses include a
course challenge that can help you
quickly find where your child needs
practice and where they're already good
to go
to get there scroll to the bottom of the
course page
and click start course challenge
these usually take 30 to 45 minutes and
will give you some good clues about
where to direct their learning
you can also suggest to your child that
they start one grade level below their
current grade or even start at
kindergarten and work their way up
if you would like to track your child's
progress you can create a parent account
go to
www.khanacademy.org and click sign up in
the upper right corner
on the sign up page select parent
now you can sign up with google facebook
or you can sign up with email and create
a username and password
once you sign up you'll be taken to your
parent dashboard
click add a child
then click the my child already has an
account link
enter your child's email address and
click next
your child will receive an email with a
link to confirm the connection to your
account
once your child activates via the link
refresh your parent dashboard and click
your child's username
this takes you to the progress report
where you can keep track of what they're
learning and how much time they're
spending
your child can also see this report
through their account by clicking
progress in the left navigation
thanks for watching and we hope you and
your child enjoy learning on khan
academy
you